pour en parler nous sommes avec leïla
hamzaoui avocate présidente d'honneur de
l'union des jeunes avocats à paris
leila zlaoui bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on vient
d'entendre caroline mécary elle parle
d'un enjeu démocratique pour tous les
français où la rejoignent et je la
rejoins parce que cette réforme des
retraites qui frappe durement les
avocats et le contexte compliqué des
relations avec le gouvernement et en
particulier avec le ministère de la
justice s'inscrit dans un contexte plus
global ou en fait ça n'arrête pas aller
réforme qui porte atteinte au ministère
d'avocat et à la possibilité pour les
justiciables d'avoir accès à un avocat
et donc c'est on a l'impression d'un
rouleau compresseur effectivement qui
essaye de se débarrasser de cette
profession donc au fond la poursuite de
la grève que vous avez voté elle est
aussi le signe d'un mal plus profond de
votre profession d'un mal plus profond
et d'un mépris très profond jeu très
simplement dans le contexte de
négociation où les avocats n'ont cessé
de dénoncer l'absence de réelles
concessions et de réelles avancées du
gouvernement
on a appris à quelques jours de notre
de notre dernière réunion avec le
gouvernement que il venait d'inscrire
dans un projet de loi une disposition
qui permettait aux assureurs de réduire
les honoraires versés à l'avocat dans le
cadre des dispositifs de protection j'ai
eu 10 juillet juridique donc on est dans
un vraiment dans une volonté de porter
atteinte à la capacité de l'avocat
accompagner ses clients
est ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
souffrir d'une image de privilégier
c'est ce qu'on peut entendre un parfois
dans la population
est ce que cette image c'est celle du
gouvernement et du chef de l'état à
votre endroit selon vous alors c'est les
éléments de langage qu il pilonne sans
arrêt pour mais qui sont au fur et à
mesure moins perçu comme cela parce que
la réalité elle est toute autre
on a beaucoup fait de pédagogie pour
expliquer la situation des avocats qui
est excessivement compliqué pour un très
grand nombre de confrères mais aussi
parce que cela dépasse cette question
aujourd'hui
si tous les libéraux parce qu'il n'ya
pas que les avocats tout là tous les
métiers de proximité tous ces métiers du
savoir qui accompagne les gens partout
en france sur les territoires sont dans
la rue et sont en difficulté c'est pas
parce que ce sont des nantis qui
préservent leurs droits mais parce que
aussi au delà de ça il préserve ceux de
leurs clients de leurs patients et et
ceux des français qui ont besoin de ces
métiers pour pouvoir continuer à vivre
correctement ce pays l'enjeu
démocratique que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure la ministre a donné des gages
pas de baisse des pensions pas de
doublement des cotisations ni même
d'augmentation brutale tout en
soulignant que le gouvernement a indiqué
qu'il était prêt à retenir d'autres
scénarii lissant davantage encore cette
hausse
et puis enfin le maintien de la caisse
de retraite des avocats qui restera
l'interlocuteur unique de la profession
s'est toujours pas suffisant pour vous
bien sûr tous est rien en réalité
alors c'est bien habillé c'est bien
c'est bien marketé on a fait des heures
et des heures de réunion avec leurs
services mais malheureusement tout cela
il faut c'est à dire que le lissage qui
nous est proposé et c'était évoqué par
ma consoeur dans une interview il nous
et il nous est proposé de nous couper
nos réserves pour les affecter à payer
nos cotisations dons qu'ils ont proposé
d'enlever ce qui appartient à nos
retraités pour l'affecter à payer nos
cotisations mais l'état lui ne fait
aucune concession c'est à dire qu'il ne
perd pas un centime ils prélèvent bien
ses cotisations majoré et puis il ya
tout un tas de situations qu'on
apportait à leur attention
les tensions ne sont absolument pas
garanti il n'y a pas de système notre
caisse et dépourvue de tout pouvoir et
elle ne peut plus collectés donc elle ne
peut plus assurer les pensions donc en
réalité ce sont des moi j'appelle ça des
des propositions de papier il n'y a rien
et rien dans ce contexte avec ses
propositions que vous dites de papier
est ce qu'une sortie de crise à court
terme est possible sachant que le
dialogue est toujours pas rompu le
dialogue n'est pas rompu néanmoins il ya
un préalable qui est cette question de
la possibilité pour les assureurs
d'imposer des honoraires à l'avocat dans
la loi azap qui est qui vient d'être
d'être présenté le dialogue n'est pas
rompu
le conseil national des barreaux a voté
qu'il souhaitait ne pas fermer la porte
mais exigeait des propositions certaines
la sortie de crise elle m'apparaît
compliqué dès lors qu aujourd'hui les
revendications élémentaires qui sont les
nôtres et notamment même celle d'avoir
des chiffrages précis c'est lui l'auteur
fiable voilà cela aujourd'hui ça n'a pas
été fait on a donné en 6 juin en juillet
à leur demande si cas type qui
correspondent à la typologie de la
profession d'avocat ils nous ont indiqué
qu'ils nous les donne en septembre puis
en novembre et aujourd'hui on les a
toujours pas ils ont inventé des cas on
en a beaucoup parlé le fameux françois
et puis marion mais qui n'étaient pas
des cas réels
aujourd'hui on n'a toujours aucune
simulation un simulateur a été mis en
ligne par un syndicat et le gouvernement
lui a demandé de le retirer
immédiatement pierce que les résultats
étaient catastrophiques et n'arrangeait
pas gouvernement un simulateur fiable de
par le gouvernement ce serait un premier
pas déjà pour vous je pense que ce
serait un premier pas mais ça ne
changerait pas la question de fond qui
est de la teinte économique qui est
porté à la profession d'avocat et à tous
les libéraux par le dispositif tel qu'il
est fait qu'il n'a pas pris en compte la
particularité économique des libéraux et
le fait qu'ils payent leur propre outil
de travail leur propre rémunération
leurs propres charges sociales leur
propre protection sociale qui ne peuvent
pas assumer la charge que le
gouvernement entre
alors demande massive de renvoi de mise
en liberté multiples points de droit
soulevée à chaque audience la mécanique
en ce moment judiciaire est mise à mal
on constate c'est la méthode pour vous
c'est une méthode efficace pour vous
faire entendre selon vous la méthode
elle est efficace en ce sens que les
avocats portent avec les magistrats et
les greffiers le personnel de justice à
bout de bras un service public qui est
mourant qui n'a pas de moyens on en
parle de d'avocats qui sont obligés de
fournir de la papeterie haut magistrat
et aujourd'hui ce que démontre ses
actions massives
c'est que quand l'avocat nous
n'acceptons plus de faire le travail de
l'état à la place de l'état
la machine se grippe ça ne fonctionne
plus donc oui c'est efficace parce
qu'aujourd'hui on l'entend et on a vu
madame belloubet à 6 pour ainsi dire
déraper samedi en nous enjoignant nous
invectives en disant de cesser le
mouvement parce que ce n'était plus
tenable
et oui donc cela démontre combien
l'avocat est essentiel au service public
de la justice avec les autres acteurs de
justice et oui nous devons maintenir la
pression à nous la maintiendrons
maintient non ce qui a été voté
tant que nous n'avons n'auront pas un
dialogue réel est vrai sur l'ensemble de
ces questions à un record de six
semaines six semaines de grève c'est
harlem heures du jamais vu pour votre
profession qu'est ce qu'on peut craindre
ce qu'on peut prendre encore un
engorgement dans les mois à venir dans
les tribunaux un engorgement alors c'est
beaucoup évoqué l'engorgement un jeu
vous donner un exemple aujourd'hui sur
les cours d'appel par exemple sur les
procédures de cour d'appel
on est à 2 à 3 ans de délai pour avoir
une date d'audience
si vous voulez le moi je veux bien que
les avocats portent la responsabilité de
la totalité de la défaillance du système
judiciaire mais je suis pas sûr que ce
soit notre mouvement qui soit la raison
des difficultés de l'engorgement
la réalité c'est que c'est toujours
chose c'est la paupérisation du service
public de la justice mais oui je pense
que on va vers quelque chose qui se
durcit les barreaux travaille
actuellement à des à d'autres formes de
sortie
et de mobilisation parce que il y a
aussi une grande proximité avec les
greffiers et les magistrats qui sont
pour la plupart assez soutenant on
essaye d'innover mais il est très clair
que la détermination des avocats et sans
faille et qui ne lâche rien pour
conclure il y aura des répercussions
pour les justiciables
alors ce que nous essayons de faire
justement c'est qu'elle n'en ai pas pour
les justiciables
aujourd'hui les actions les plus les
plus massives
ce sont les actions de défense massives
dont vous avez peut-être entendu parler
avec lesquels les justiciables sont
assez d'accord puisque ses actions à ce
qu'elle montre c'est que quand on peut
vraiment faire fonctionner la justice
les justiciables sont beaucoup mieux
défendu donc en réalité c'est cela
effectivement
sur lequel fois pillée merci beaucoup
les lames ah oui je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat de présidente d'honneur de
l'uja paris c'est l'union des jeunes
avocats